[Music]
hey guys welcome to another installment
of Harry Potter theory in this video
I'll be discussing charms enchantments
spells and curses all these terms are
used interchangeably by many and they
refer to quite similar things but what
exactly are the differences between them
this video will outline those
differences let's start with the easiest
one a spell a spell is a very very broad
term for any piece of magic it refers to
a controlled manifestation of magic that
affects the world in a supernatural way
it can range immensely and includes all
manners of magic from stunning someone
to levitating an object spells are
generally cast by a witch or wizard and
are usually produced via some form of
incantation because of the generic
nature of the word spell it could be the
appropriate term to use in almost any
circumstance spell is a nonspecific
umbrella term that would cover other
things like charms hexes curses jinxes
and enchantments though using the term
spell is almost never incorrect some
situations might warrant a more specific
term as spell is so broad next let's
dive into charms a charm is an
expression that refers to spells which
add certain properties to objects or
individuals charms should not be
confused with transfigurations as
Transfiguration refers to a spell that
changes what the object is rather than
just changing the properties of the
object there are countless charms in
Harry Potter that cover an extensive
number of outcomes some notable charms
from the films include a resto momentum
the slowing charm Dumbledore uses this
charm to slow down a falling Harry
Potter after he was attacked by
Dementors in his Quidditch match ascend
yo ascend do propels the cast to high
into the air Harry uses this charm the
Triwizard Tournament to get out of the
black lake bombarda Maxima Bambara
Maxima is a charm that creates a large
violent explosion Bambara Maxima is the
more extreme version of
bombarda which produces smaller
explosions Bambara Maxima is notably
used by umbrage in her attempt to find
them below the army another form of
charm is an enchantment though the lines
are a bit blurred here the main
difference is that an enchantment is
generally used to apply a charm like
effect to something for extended period
of time
these would include protective
enchantments like the fidelia's charm or
protego Maxima I could go on and on but
you get it charms can really come in
handy with all that being said about
charms let's jump into curses funnily
enough a curse is actually also a type
of charm a dark charm the expression
curse is used exclusively for the charms
that are darkest in nature the worst
kinds of dark magic immediately your
mind should probably jump to the three
unforgivable curses
Avada Kedavra the killing curse crucio
the Cruciatus curse and Imperia the
Imperius curse technically a curse is
defined as any spell that affects an
object in a negative manner typically
associated with some sort of discomfort
this definition applies to regular dark
charms and curses but generally occurs
is more severe the unforgivable curses
are the strongest known dark charms in
existence causing excruciating pain mind
control and death other examples of
curses include blood maledictions which
are curses that affect the targets body
but have been passed down through
generations of their family and taboo a
curse which designates a word as a key
in revealing the location of the Asura
Baltimore place this curse on his own
name so that he would know when people
said it hexes and jinxes are also
considered to be dark charms but a less
severe than curses in order of severity
EKOS jinx hex curse jinxes are mainly
irritating amusing and harmless examples
of jinxes include the dancing feet spell
which forces the victim to dance wildly
and the vermiculite jinx which turns
things into worms hexes are slightly
more malicious than jinxes examples of
hexes include the sardine hex which
causes sardines to come out of the
victims nose and knee reversal hex which
switches the victims knees from the
front of their leg to the back
so I hope that provides you guys with
some clarity on the differences between
spells charms curses hexes jinxes and
enchantments that's all for this video I
hope you enjoyed it if you liked the
video please remember to hit the like
button until next time you're a wizard
Harry
you